- Okay.
Hello and welcome, everyone.
My name is Marc, I'm an
engineer on the DSQL team,
and this is DAT439.
This is a deep dive
into Amazon Aurora DSQL
and its architecture.
Last year, my colleague Marc Brooker,
gave a really fantastic talk
with the same title as this one
where we gave a broad
overview of the service
and its capabilities.
There's a lot going on
under the cover of DSQL,
and so this year we have a
series of deep dive talks
where we're gonna go much deeper
into specific areas of the architecture.
In this talk, we're gonna be talking about
how DSQL manages connections?
What the architecture of the
query processor looks like,
and the architecture of the session
routing layer in front of it looks like.
Hope you enjoy the talk.
But first, let's do a quick
recap of what Aurora DSQL is.
DSQL is a distributed implementation
of a relational database.
Relational databases are
awesome. They're older than I am.
You can run complex queries,
you can involve your schema,
add indexes on the fly.
Meanwhile, we have services like DynamoDB.
We've been figuring out how to build
and run distributed services
for quite a long time at this point.
And the really cool thing
about architectures like Dynamo
is that they don't have
a single point of failure
that they can scale horizontally
rather than vertically.
DSQL is based on Postgres.
We're running Postgres under the covers,
and it's a database that has been designed
for running transactional workloads.
And so our customers have been asking us
to bridge these two worlds,
the world of relational,
the world of distributor database,
and at the same time, our
customers have been asking us
for a fully serverless database,
one where there are no
server to provision,
manage or patch,
a service where you can pay per use,
a service that scales up
but also all the way down.
This is what it looks like
to create a DSQL cluster.
I'm really proud of this page.
This is something that we intend
to keep as simple as it is,
there's no scroll bar here.
You can click Create Cluster,
and in just five seconds,
that's something we recently released.
You can have a cluster ready to go.
There's nothing on this page
that you have to decide upfront, right?
There is no maintenance windows,
there's no VPC settings.
Everything on here is
something you can change later.
Tags, deletion protection.
You can re-encrypt your cluster
with the different key later,
you can toggle the resource
based policies later.
So if you want, you can just click create
and off you're going.
Here's another feature our
team released recently.
This is the query editor.
What's really cool about this,
is this is a Postgres application
running in your web browser,
speaking web sockets directly to DSQL.
Because DSQL is based on Postgres,
our expectation is that you can pick up
the vast majority of
Postgres based libraries,
whether that's libpq based or
JDBC or anything like that,
and connect to DSQL.
So how does this all work?
We have application, maybe that's a shell
or something that you built on Lambda.
It's connecting to DSQL,
and we're sending SQL
statements to a component
called the Query Processor.
This is gonna be the
star of our show today.
And the QP is receiving
the Postgres wire protocol.
It's receiving SQL from your applications,
and it's interpreting and
running those queries.
The second key component is the Journal.
The journal is our
distributed transaction log.
It's a core building block at AWS.
It powers services like S3
and the journal is where we
get our durability guarantee.
In single region, when the
journal accepts a transaction,
it's writing it to at least
two availability zones.
And in a multi-region configuration,
we're getting our transactions replicated
to at least one other AWS region.
And the third key component is Storage.
Storage is a service that our
team built from the ground up
designed to meet the performance
needs that we had of DSQL.
And the way storage fits into this picture
is that it connects to the journal.
It learns about transactions
that you've committed
and it's taken those transactions
and updating its local view of the world
so that we can run queries.
And so, when we send a SQL
Select statement to DSQL,
it's the QPs job to parse,
plan and execute that query
and turn that into a series
of low level read
operations against storage.
Meanwhile, if you're running any DML,
like an insert statement,
any rows that you insert into DSQL
are gonna reside in the
memory of the query processor.
Nothing's been written to the disc.
If you run an update statement,
the QP is first gonna turn that into
a series of select statements to go
and read the existing
values of those rows,
and then apply anything
in the update statement
like a set or, you know,
increment might balance by one
to produce new versions
of those rows in memory.
And so as you run your transaction,
the QP is doing all of this
work, ephemerally in memory.
And if your connection breaks
or if you type rollback,
that data's simply gone.
Meanwhile, if you commit your transaction,
the QP is gonna send that
transaction over the network.
Eventually, it'll be
written to the journal
again to at least two availability zones
and this is the point
of commit in our system.
Storage, again, is
subscribed to the journal.
It's learning about these transactions
and it's keeping itself up to date.
Now, you may be wondering
what about consistency?
DSQL is strongly consistent.
And the way we do this is through
a time-based synchronization protocol.
When your transaction starts,
the Query Processor is doing two things.
First, it's using the
EC2 Time Sync Service
which is based on GPS satellite clocks
to get a really accurate,
microsecond accurate reading
of what the current time is.
The second thing it does is
use the AWS ClockBound Service
to correct even that very
accurate time measurement
for any potential errors.
And by doing this, we get called
a linear risible timestamps,
which is to say it's a
value that's guaranteed
to be in the future of
any commit timestamps.
The QP is going to include that timestamp
in request to storage.
And by doing this, we
guarantee that storage
has always seen the latest data.
Storage implements multi-version
concurrency control.
And so we'll return results
for precisely the timestamp
that we asked for,
which means that as we run our transaction
and many seconds may pass while
we're going back and forth,
we see a frozen moment in time.
So because DSQL is strongly consistent,
this means that we can open
additional connections.
These different connections
can run on different query processes
on different physical hosts
in different EC2 availability zones,
or in the case of multi-region,
even in different AWS regions
and still get strongly consistent results.
The SQL is also active-active,
which means that any of
these query processes
can also update data.
And the way they do
that is by coordinating
with a service called the Adjudicator,
which sits in front of the journal.
The Adjudicator implements a
concurrency control technique
known as optimistic concurrency control.
And the idea behind this
is that we take that bundle
of everything we wanted
to do in our transaction,
and the adjudicator's going to go look
at other commits that
have been made recently,
and check if there are any conflicts.
We are not gonna go deep into OCC today.
Again, in the talk last
year with the same title,
we went into much more detail,
and yesterday we gave
a 500 level talk about
Optimistic Concurrency Control
if you'd like to learn more.
DSQL implements hands-free
automatic scaling
through a number of techniques,
it does this automatically
and out of the box.
So on this picture,
any number of things might have happened.
Let's pretend there's
rescaling happening here.
DSQL is continuously backing up your data,
and as we open more of these connections
that are able to drive more and
more traffic to the service,
DSQL will use those recent snapshots
to create clones of storage.
Those clones will go and
connect into the journal.
They will learn about recent transactions,
they'll keep themselves up to date,
and then the query processes
will intelligently load
balance across those replicas.
Another thing this picture might represent
is splitting for size, right?
Like as we put more data into the service,
these replicas are gonna become bigger.
And so DSQL will try and keep
them of a manageable size.
And the reason we do that
is because if we keep the data sets small,
we can improve performance,
and in the case that one
of our replicas fails,
we can bring a replacement
online very quickly
because it doesn't have
too much data to restore.
DSQL can also scale out the journal layer,
and it does that through automatic
and transparent sharding.
And we'll start to send
some of your updates
to some adjudicators in some journals
and some of your updates
to other adjudicators.
For both the read and write scaling,
DSQL does this very proactively,
so it's monitoring an increase in load,
and it implements these scaling
techniques transparently.
And it actually doesn't matter
what the sharding strategy it picks is,
because DSQLs fully capable
of doing cross-shot commits.
Okay, that's our crash
course out of the way.
We're gonna now start to
speak a little bit about
how connections work in DSQL.
Before we do that,
let's set the stage and talk about
how connections would
work in vanilla Postgres.
This is Postgres that you
may have downloaded off
the internet installed in your laptop,
or Postgres that you're getting on EC2
maybe through RDS or Aurora.
So our application is gonna connect in,
it's gonna do some kind
of credential exchange.
Postgres has many
mechanisms for doing this.
Let's say we are doing a user
password credential exchange.
The server is gonna look at our password,
it's sorted in the database,
it's gonna make sure that
it matches what we ask for.
And once it's authenticated
and authorized our connection,
the server is going to fork itself.
This is the Unix fork system call
and so we're gonna get a dedicated process
for our connection.
And as we open more connections
either from the same host
or from a different host,
we're gonna land up with
more of these sessions.
And each of our connections,
each of these sessions
is getting its own dedicated process.
And because of this, each one
of these connections consumes
some number of resources on the service,
even if you're not doing anything.
And so, at some point we may
need to get a bigger host
simply to have more connections.
And so what we're gonna do now
is go through a little bit of a journey
that many of you may have
been on several times
as you've built applications
against the relational database
and started to scale or solve problems
like how to manage heat, or
availability, or failover.
And so we have our application,
it has a single customer,
we've just gotten started.
And the first question that
we may have to answer is,
how do we secure this endpoint?
Postgres is about a million
lines of sea, it's 40 years old.
And it's a very performance
sensitive code, right?
There's tons of optimizations.
And so just by running this
service on the internet,
you have to run the risk of
some kind of security breach.
It may not even be in Postgres itself,
it may be a security issue
with the operating system
or through libraries like OpenSSL
that Postgres is linked to.
And even if Postgres itself is secure,
we may have something
like a password, right?
Maybe you put it on a sticky note
on your machine, please don't do that.
Best practice here is
you can do some sort of
a password rotation
through Secrets Manager,
but still you have a fundamental property
that if somebody leaks that password,
they may have access to your database.
And so this is a common
reason for customers to,
you know, run their database
in something like a VPC,
which can really complicate
the lives of developers
trying to connect to and
work with the database.
Now, hopefully we have
more than one customer,
as that other customer starts to connect
and use our service.
We can't just have one connection open
to the database, right?
And so we're gonna need at
least one more connection
so we can do work in parallel.
Now, you don't want to be
opening that connection
as that customer arrives.
Opening a connection in
Postgres can take some time,
sometimes as much as a second,
because we have to do a
bunch of things, right?
We have to establish a TCP connection,
we have to set up TLS,
we have to do multiple round
trips to do handshaking,
we have to do credential exchange,
we have to fork that backend process,
that backend process has to get ready.
And then finally, our
application can prepare any data,
like prepared statements
before it can get going.
And so to solve this problem,
many customers will create
client side connection pools
that ahead of time, open
a bunch of connections.
We move all of that slow
stuff off the critical path.
And so when one of our
customers comes along
with an API request,
we can just pop a connection
out of the pool and get going.
Which leads us to a question, right?
How big should this pool be?
If our application is running
at 10 transactions per second
and you look on your monitoring graph
and it's just sitting at 10,
well, that probably doesn't mean
that you can use a pool size of 10, right?
Because if we zoom into any minute,
right down to the second,
we may see spikes in concurrency
because our customers
may not always be doing
work at a steady rate.
This is a problem known
as peak to average,
and it may lead you to
require a much bigger pool
than your steady state rate.
Let's pretend it's about 110x increase.
This is a formula from the
RDS documentation that says,
for every gigabyte of
memory that an instance has,
you can have roughly 10 connections.
And so if we need a hundred
connections for our application,
that means we can use the
smallest instance type
that micro over there.
But, of course, we don't want to run
one copy of our application, right?
We want to be able to do deployments,
we want to be able to survive the loss
of an availability zone.
And so if we are running in a typical
three replica scenario,
you may think that we can set
that pool size to 33 only,
but it actually doesn't work like that.
Because again, if we lose a host,
then the surviving hosts
need to be able to survive
to handle those spikes.
And so now we need 300 connections.
We can no longer use a micro.
This is really common pattern
that customers have to
increase their instance size
just to get more connections.
But you'll notice that the
second part of this formula,
that 5,000 says that even if you're using
an M84XL with 64 gigs of memory,
or the beast of a machine, the
48XL with 768 gigs of memory,
you can still only have 5,000 connections.
To solve this problem,
it's very common to deploy
something like PgBouncer
or if you're an RDS customer,
then you can use RDS Proxy.
And the way this works
is that you're connect into the proxy,
and the proxy is gonna
hold those 300 connections
and only use the hundred
that you actually need on the backend,
which is gonna save resources
and improve performance.
This can be a really great solution
in managing this complexity,
but it's just one more
thing for you to worry about
to configure and to pay for.
Here's another challenge.
What host are we connecting to, right?
We have a single writer,
a single place that we can do mutations,
a single place where we can
get strongly consistent reads.
And if it becomes unavailable
or you can't contact it,
then things are go about to go bad.
You have to somehow fence this machine off
so it can no longer do writes.
We have to find a standby,
hopefully we have one ready,
or we have to restore from backup.
We have to kick the primary out of DNS,
we have to bring the standby in.
We have to make sure that
our application is ready
to reconnect to that machine.
And even if you do all of this right,
this can still lead to
minutes or hours of downtime.
And if you're using all
of the best practices,
really you shouldn't expect less
than 30 seconds of downtime.
Here's another challenge, scaling, right?
If we need to scale out reads,
we're gonna add read replicas,
we're gonna need to
configure reader endpoints.
We're gonna have to teach our application,
which of our APIs can
tolerate eventual consistency
in our read-only and then
start to do some sort of
traffic splitting in the application.
Some of these read replicas
may be further behind than others.
So our load balancing is not
simply distributing the load,
it's also excluding hosts
that we shouldn't talk to.
And even if you get all of that right,
you're still left with
eventual consistency,
which is very difficult to reason about
and build correct applications against.
And so, as we were thinking about
what we wanted to build with DSQL,
we were talking to customers
to understand these pain points.
These are the kinds of
things that kept coming up.
And if you really think about it,
many of these problems are caused
by the single fundamental property
that we have this writer,
a single point of success.
It needs to be there, it
needs to be available,
it needs to be scaled,
it needs to be secure,
and it needs to have enough capacity
to do the work that you need out of it.
Meanwhile, with DSQL, we have
an active-active architecture.
In DSQL, any of these query processes
can accept reads or writes,
and all of our reads are
gonna be strongly consistent.
And so this was the start of our journey
as we were building DSQL.
How can we take this architecture,
put something like a load
balance in front of it,
fully encapsulate all of the problems
that we've just described,
and offer customers a just
much simpler experience.
And so this is our vision, our North star,
our customer's gonna come
in with their application
and there is simply gonna
be given a query processor
that they can use for the
duration of their connection.
Okay, so we are thinking
about how to build this,
and we are working backwards.
And the first question that we have is,
we have this picture in mind,
but do we have one of
these pictures per cluster?
When you go to the DSQL API
and you click that create cluster button,
do you get a dedicated load balancer
with your own query
processes running behind it.
Which leads up to the following question,
which is how many QP should
be behind this load balancer?
Now, if we had a dedicated
endpoint per cluster,
this question becomes very
difficult to answer, right.
We would require our customers
to give us some kind of hint.
"Hey, I need a hundred connections.
I need 200 connections."
And so, now each of these QPs,
they're just a Unix process, right?
That we are forking to accept more work.
And so our minimum unit would be
whatever we can pack onto
the smallest instance.
Let's say the smallest
instance can run 50 QPs.
That would mean that if
you created a DSQL cluster
and you went to that little box
where you can hit plus or minus,
the fewest connections
you could offer is 50,
but as we saw before, that's not enough
because what if that machine died, right.
We want at least redundant
capacity in other zones.
We would also not be able to offer you
51 connections, right, it
would be 50, or 100, or 150.
And then we want to think
about patching, right.
How do we do deployments to these hosts?
And so it very quickly became clear to us
that we should not do this.
Instead, what we should work towards
is a single shared endpoint,
an endpoint that any cluster can use
and an endpoint that simply has
as many query processes behind it
that are needed for any of our customers
at any point in time.
And if we're gonna build this endpoint,
we need to play well with
the Postgres ecosystem
because if DSQL was simply an AWS Service,
we could design whatever API we wanted
such as, "Hey, customer,
you need to tell us which
cluster you're using
when you run a transaction."
But because we speak in
the Postgres wire protocol,
we need to fit within the bounds
of what that protocol could offer.
And so as we were looking
around for our options,
we very quickly settled
on using a feature of TLS called SNI.
And the way this works is when
you create a DSQL cluster,
we generate a random identifier
that's that colored bit YEA,
and that cluster is gonna
get its own endpoint
using a feature of Route
53 called an alias record.
So it looks like it's its own a record,
but in fact, it's actually just a pointer
to our shared endpoint.
And the way this works
is that when your client
is establishes a connection
and starts doing that TLS handshake,
the first thing it's gonna do
is send a message called the Client Hello.
And if you see that blue bit,
it includes the name of the server
that it's trying to connect to.
And then on the server side,
we can take a look at that Client Hello,
we can strip that name out,
and now we know which
cluster's trying to be...
Which cluster you're connecting to.
So this feature server name indication
is a TLS feature it's
not a Postgres feature,
but it's been integrated into
Postgres since version 14.
(person coughs)
Okay, so now we have the
shared endpoint. We have SNI.
And what we're gonna do
is that we're gonna run this
big fleet of EC2 instances.
It's the job of the service team
to make sure that those instances
are sufficient for all
of our capacity needs,
and that we're gonna be taking on the job
of making sure that they're up to date.
And so if our application comes in,
we could have the low
balance to do something
like round robin and just pick out a QP,
so here we go, one, two, three,
we're now connected to
all three of the hosts.
And now look at the top.
We are gonna have another
customer come along
this fuab red cluster.
They're gonna come in,
they're gonna get a connection
on the same host as us,
all's well.
Except, oh no, they're a baddie.
They've found a security
vulnerability in Postgres, right.
And they fully intend to exploit that.
So they're connecting in,
they're running some kind
of Bobby Drop Tables query,
and they're gonna break out of Postgres
and now they have access
to the environment
that they've broken out into.
And because they're just a process running
on the same machine as our orange cluster,
they're gonna have access
to everything on that host,
and they could potentially
read or write data
from other customers.
So this is a big deal.
And at AWS, the bar
for this kind of design
is not process level isolation,
it's not containers,
it's hardware level virtualization.
Now, fortunately, this is the same problem
that our friends over in
Lambda faced many years ago,
which they solved by building
a hardware level virtualization
library known as Firecracker,
which gives us a microVM.
And by microVM, we mean
it's almost exactly
the same thing as an EC2 instance,
but it's designed for machines
that use much fewer resources.
Now, VMs launch in milliseconds
and have minimal overhead,
but even Firecracker outta the
box wasn't quite good enough
for the performance we wanted
to offer our customers.
And so what we do is
we have a little agent
running on our hosts,
and these agents are
going to create these VMs
ahead of time into a Warm Pool.
So here we are filling up a Warm Pool.
I've shown six on the slide,
but in reality, we are
packing hundreds of these VMs
onto a single machine.
And then when our application
is coming to connect
and it's been assigned this host,
we can simply take one of
these QPs out of the pool,
and then we connect directly into that QP
and then in the background,
the agents is gonna go
fill up the warm pool.
And because this is an
in-memory operation,
it's essentially popping
an item from a linked list
and establishing a TCP connection,
this happens really fast
and with minimal overhead.
However, there is a really
complicated economic challenge here.
And so in order to explain this to you,
let's look more closely
at how connections work
in standard Postgres.
So applications connected into the server,
and you can see that that server
is using some amount of memory, right?
The dotted box represents
memory available to the system.
Each of these blocks is
something like a page of memory,
and you can see that our servers
using many hundreds of megabytes of memory
just to be running.
Now, when we fork one of
these backend processes,
even though that new process
has essentially the same amount
of memory requirements to run,
the operating system is gonna be cunning,
and it's gonna use pointers
to say that actually
this underlying memory
that I cloned from has not been modified.
And so that both of these processes
can share the same physical pages.
And so as we open more connections,
we can keep doing this trick,
and this is gonna significantly reduce
the overhead of running
these additional processes.
Now, each of these connections, of course,
needs its own memory, right.
Pay attention to the orange one.
It's running some kind of query.
And so it's claiming new memory pages
as it's doing something
like loading all your data
into memories that are consulted
or run some sort of aggregation function.
Meanwhile, over in our Firecracker world,
we have something that
looks very different.
Here's a VM we've just
launched it into the pool
and it's running a full operating system,
a full copy of Linux.
It's running our Postgres server
that's gonna handle just one connection,
and it's also got a bunch
of additional services
that our team installed into that Sandbox.
So we can do things like monitor,
manage system lifecycle,
get logs out of the Sandbox.
And if you add all of this up,
we are looking at many
hundreds of megabytes.
Just pretend it's 700 megabytes.
And if we do this a couple of times,
we're almost at three gigs of memory.
So what do we do about this?
A Firecracker has a
really cool trick here,
which was again, developed by
our friends over in Lambda,
which we've blogged about
extensively called SnapStart.
And the way this works is
that when our host comes up
for the very first time, it's
gonna create one of these VMs.
I call it the seed
because we're gonna use it
to grow new VMs.
And when the seed comes up,
we do everything that you might expect.
We launch Linux, we start Postgres,
we make sure everything's healthy,
and we get right to the point
where we're ready to accept
our first connection.
And then we talk to our
agent, we say, "We're ready."
What the agent's gonna do
is it's gonna pause that VM
and it's gonna take all of
them, all of those memory pages,
and write them to a file
called the MEM file.
It's gonna be persistent on disc.
And then at this point,
our seed has done its job.
We can kill it.
Now that we have our seed,
we can start new clones from
that seed, we can grow new VMs.
And these VMs have the
exact same memory layout.
In fact, they're identical copies.
They think they have the same IP address.
They think that time is
what the original seed had.
They think they have the same Mac address.
They're identical in every way.
Except just like with fork,
because we've memory mapped
in this file on disc.
The contents of this VM
are actually just pointers
to the original snapshot.
So far we haven't saved any memory,
but as we start to launch additional VMs
from that same snapshot,
we get to use that same
pointer chasing technique.
And just like before,
as one of our VM starts to do unique work,
it can claim additional memory
and we are only paying
for that unique memory.
Okay.
Instead of just doing round
robin across these VMs,
we have a service that runs
behind the load balance
called the Relay service.
And when your application connects in
and it starts doing that TLS handshake,
it is the relay that it's talking to.
Relay is a service that we built
from the ground up in Rust,
and it uses the s2n library
so that we can just have assurance
about the security of the service.
And it uses s2ns capability
to parse that SNI value.
Now, the next thing your
application is gonna do
is send over what's called
an authentication token,
which I just wanna take
a moment to explain.
Typically, when you're using
an AWS service like S3,
let's say we're doing
a get object request,
that is an HDP request, right.
We have a bunch of
headers, we have a body,
and your SDK is going to sign that request
using your AWS credentials
to produce a new header
using the Signature
version four algorithm.
And this signature is used
to prevent any tampering.
So if somebody was able
to intercept that request
and try and change the bucket
or the object key that you
were trying to download,
then the signature would no longer match.
The other thing the signature does
is it allows the S3 service to
understand who the caller is,
so we can do any
authorization enforcement.
Now, S3 is a really cool
feature called pre-signed URLs,
where instead of actually
signing that request
and sending it over the network,
you can just take a frozen
version of that request,
it looks like a URL,
it has the signature as a query parameter,
and you can share that URL
with one of your friends
and they will be able
to just go to that URL
without an AWS SDK and download the object
that you gave them permission to.
You're not giving them your credentials.
They can't write data to your bucket,
and they can only download
precisely what you asked them to.
The other thing you can do
with SIG V4 request is put an expiry in
for requests that are sent by your SDK,
they typically are expiring
something like five minutes,
but with an S3 pre-sign URL,
you can customize that
value for up to a week.
So this is the underlying
machinery that DSQL uses.
It's actually the same machinery
that I am authentication and RDS uses.
And so what your
application is going to do
is use the DSQL SDK to generate one
of these authentication tokens.
This is very fast.
It takes us a few nanoseconds
because this is something that
AWS has invested in heavily.
If you're talking to S3 or DynamoDB,
every single request you
make is being signed.
But what we are doing
here is just generating
one of these tokens periodically
or once per connection request.
And this allows QSQL to integrate
with the IAM Control plane,
sorry, the IAM Data plane.
And it's gonna do some
fetching of your keys
for your account,
fetching of your policies and your tags.
And it does this very efficiently
so that relay can authenticate
and authorize your requests
in many times locally using its cache.
At this point, we have
established your AWS identity.
We're able to enforce any policies.
For example, you can say,
users in this group or users in this role
can only access clusters
tagged in certain ways.
And if you've used
resource-based policies on DSQL,
this is a really great place
to enforce things like,
I must be connecting
from certain IP addresses
or through private link.
After writing login
attempts at CloudTrail,
DSQL has established the
identity of your user,
and it'll talk to a placement service.
Now, the job of the placement service
is to keep track of our fleet,
we'll go into that more in a few minutes,
and suggest one of these query processes
for your application to connect to.
So we've picked a host, we've picked a QP,
and then the relay is simply going to send
your connection over to the QP.
At this point, the relay
doesn't really have
anything interesting to do.
You see, the relay is a service
that we built from the ground up.
It's written in Rust.
And those first few
messages, the TLS handshake,
the Postgres authentication messages,
this requires complex protocol parsing,
the Postgres protocol
can lead you to making
some very silly security mistakes.
For example, messages have a length,
and if you get that length wrong
when you're assigning buffers,
you can have all sorts of
overflow and underflow attacks
or arbitrary code execution.
And so the way we approached this in relay
is that we designed it to process
as few packets as possible.
And when we implemented
the protocol parsing code
for those packets, we
were extremely careful
and worked closely with our security teams
to make sure that we
had done this correctly.
But now that we've done that work,
relay really has nothing
interesting to do.
Everything else that's gonna
happen on this connection
should be handled by Postgres.
And so what we do is
we move the TLS session
into the Sandbox.
Now this is super cool
and the way it works
is that a TLS session is a
layer seven concept, right.
It's happening right at
the top of the OSI model.
And we take all of the
ephemeral encryption keys
that are used for that session,
and we package them over the network
and we securely send them
into the query processor.
At this point, we are gonna use a function
that's zeroes out the memory in relay.
And so Relay can no longer
decode anything else
that happens on this connection.
And so if our application sends
any data into the query processor,
it's gonna take that data,
it's gonna send it over a TLS connection,
it's getting encrypted,
it's gonna flow encrypted
through the network load balancer
through the relay,
and it's gonna arrive at the QP,
which now has the keys
necessary to decrypt our data.
Okay, let's talk about Pooling.
When our application connects
into one of these hosts,
instead of simply taking one of these QPs
out of the warm pool and that's it,
what we instead do is we move
it into a per cluster pool,
which is gonna hold
capacity just for that host.
And the reason we do that is,
watch what happens when we
open the second connection.
We have not dragged an additional
QP out of the warm pool.
Now, I forgot to fill the
warm pool on the slide,
but keep in mind that the agent
is continuously doing that.
And so now that first
connection we opened,
it started to flash.
What's gonna happen is
it's gonna be able to use
one of these QPs directly
from the pool, right.
But we have two connections open.
What happens if that other
connection becomes busy?
Well, you don't have to
do anything about this.
DSQL is going to
automatically take another QP
out of the warm pool.
Again, these query processes
are already running.
And so this happens extremely quickly
with a very minimal performance impact.
And the reason we do this is
because think back to those problems
that our customers were telling about
right in the beginning.
Like as customers want to scale
their application fleet out,
they want to deal with this
peak to average problem.
And so typically open
many more connections
than they actively intend to use,
and we didn't want DSQL customers
to have to worry about
anything like running PgBouncer
or running RDS proxy
because that would just add
another hop in the network,
that would be something
else you'd have to pay for,
you would have to run many of them
to great get high availability.
And it would be have to be something
that you scale in addition
to everything else in DSQL.
And so by doing it like this,
we've built pooling into the service
and there's simply no need
for you to worry about that.
Now, that placement service
I mentioned earlier,
what it's doing is continuously
patrolling the fleet.
So at a very high frequency,
each of our placement services
is connecting into these agents,
and it's asking it questions,
"How busy are you?
How many connections do you have?
How many of these are being used?
How much memory do you have?
What is the CPU load?
For these specific clusters,
how many Sandboxes do you have?
How many of them are being used?"
And it's doing this all the time.
The placement service is
another service we built
from the ground up in Rust
and it does all of this in memory.
And so when the relay
asks the placement service
where it should place a new connection,
the placement service
can do this very quickly
because it has very current
information sitting in memory.
And because of this, I'm not
sure if you can read that,
that bottom line, this
is from our coder's page.
By default, a DSQL cluster
has a limit of 10,000 connections,
which is twice what you
get out of the biggest
RDS instance size.
And if you want, you can configure it.
We have customers who are running
with many, many more
connections than this.
Okay, so we are opening connections.
Here, we have three open,
and it turns out one of our
metal instances has failed,
or maybe one of our relays has failed.
What's gonna happen?
Instead of experiencing a
full application outage,
we're gonna experience a one
third drop in connectivity.
Two of our connections
are still good to go.
And what our application needs to do
is open a third connection again,
it's gonna flow through the NLB,
it's gonna find a healthy relay,
and it's gonna talk to a
healthy placement service
and get us a new query processor.
Now, we can't tell your
application to reconnect, right.
There are many kinds of failure
that can happen within DSQL,
and for almost all of
these kinds of failures,
DSQL is gonna take care of
it automatically for you,
but we can't have your
application reconnect.
And so, what we decided is to put a limit
of one hour on connection age.
And so after an hour,
which is gonna be really
early on into your experience
building applications with DSQL,
either you hang up or we hang up.
Now, don't worry, we're not
gonna close the connection
while you're using it,
like if you happen to start a transaction,
you know, at 59 minutes and 59 seconds,
we'll actually give you
some breathing room.
We have some smart things
going on like jitters,
so we don't close all your
connections at the same time.
But the best practice here
is to use a client site
connection pooling library,
like we spoke about earlier.
You want to take all that
slow and expensive TLS set up,
credential exchange placement,
move that off the critical path.
That's the best practice
anyways, so while you're at it,
configure that client site pooling library
to have a maximum age of one hour.
If you want, you can do health checks.
And that's gonna mean
that when this kind of failure happens,
probably what your
application is going to do
is simply retry locally
against your connection pool
and find a healthy connection.
Now, Postgres is a fairly chatty protocol.
I think when it was designed,
probably the client and the
server were on the same machine.
But even so, when you're running
these interactive transactions
where we're sending selects
from your client to the server
getting results back in the application,
then your application is
able to look at those results
and run complex business logic
and off we go back and forth,
every time we go across the
network, we're spending time.
And so what we wanted to do in DSQL
is give you the best possible performance.
And the way we do this is
with the Route 53 feature
where your EC2's nitro card is gonna send
some additional information
as part of the DNS request,
which is gonna tag it
with the availability zone
that that server is in.
And so when you connect
to DSQL, by default,
your application is going
to go through an NLB host
in the same zone through to a
relay host in the same zone,
which is gonna talk to a
placement host in the same zone,
which is gonna give you
a QP in the same zone,
which is gonna talk to
storage in the same zone.
And by doing this,
we're giving you the
lowest possible latency.
And so as we open additional connections,
we're taking advantage of DSQLs
active-active strong consistency.
But in the event that one of our AZs
are completely unavailable,
the load balance is gonna
fall back to a healthy zone.
This is gonna give you a connection
with slightly higher latency,
but the system will remain available.
Any internal failures, for example here,
one of our storage
replicas in AZ3 has failed,
is gonna be automatically
handled by the service
by picking a healthy
replica in the same zone.
And in the event that
there are none of those,
it'll also go across AZ.
So this is a really cool
feature of Route 53.
You know, you can use it
in your own applications if you want.
And there's something that
we are very happy about
because even though DSQL being
a distributed architecture
would appear to have
more hops in this case,
there are actually cases
where connecting to DSQL
can be faster than connecting
to a single writer endpoint
because we're able to give
you a QP in the same zone
no matter where the primary is,
because in DSQL there is no primary.
Okay, let's talk about pricing.
DSQL is designed for
activity-based pricing.
So if you're familiar with DynamoDB,
where as you send, put
item, and get item requests,
you're paying for right capacity units,
you're paying for re-capacity units
based on the number of bytes
that you're putting into the system,
based on the number of
bytes that you're visiting
when you do those reads.
DSQL is a very similar concept,
but we are actually gonna take all usage
and talk about it in what we call
a Distributed Processing Unit or a DPU.
At the end of the month, you'll
see a DPU on your AWS bill.
But actually, if you go
into the usage metrics
on your DSQL clusters page,
you'll see that we break
out these DPU usages
in several ways.
So let me explain that quickly.
The QP is running Postgres,
and it's kind of like a
Lambda function, right.
In the sense that you can
ask this QP to do work,
you can have it do Fibonacci if you want.
It doesn't actually have
to do any reads or writes.
And so as you consume time
on these query processes,
we're gonna capture that time
through a compute DPU metric,
which is essentially the seconds
that you were active on this
QP, so it's per second billing.
When the QP does reads over
the network to storage,
we're gonna capture the reads that you do
in the same way that we
would do in DynamoDB.
We are looking at the
bytes that you're visiting.
Of course, if you're scanning
a table, right, with a filter,
you may visit many bytes in the table,
but the return bytes
may be smaller, right.
So think about how many
bytes you're visiting
as part of your cost optimization.
And then on the right path,
what we're doing is we are
looking at that commit payload,
and we are looking at how many bytes
you're putting into the system
and recording those is read DPUs.
And all of these are activity based,
which means that as your
application scales up,
you're simply gonna
spending more on compute,
writes and reads, and this is
how you should think about it,
you shouldn't be thinking about
how big should my machine be?
You should simply be thinking about
how much am I spending on DSQL?
Of course, when you put
data into the system,
we have to store it, right?
We have to keep it there
and ready to go when you
connect in and run a query.
And this is just gonna be
measured in gigabyte hours,
just like you would expect
from S3 or DynamoDB.
Now, DSQL can obviously
scale for you, right?
We may be adding multiple
replicas behind the scenes.
If you're running a very high throughput,
you may have 10, 15, or 100 replicas.
With DSQL, you're only paying
for a single copy of your data, right?
So don't think about
the number of replicas,
don't think about those continuous
backups that we're doing.
Just think about what
is the number of bytes
that I've put into the system.
And because of everything
we've covered in this talk,
if your application
goes to sleep at night,
because you don't have any
customers using your application,
you can simply close connections.
You don't even have to close connections.
You can leave them running if you want.
The important piece is that
you're not sending us any SQL, right.
If you're not sending us any SQL,
you're not spending any time on the QPs,
you're not spending any
of their compute DPU,
you're not doing any reads,
you're not doing any writes.
And so the only ongoing cost for DSQL
in this kind of scenario
is that storage amount.
When morning comes and you
want to get going again,
just open new connections,
everything's there, it's ready to go.
There's really no difference in DSQL
between going from 99
connections to a hundred,
compared to going from zero connection
to that first connection, right?
The way we think about this
is you're just grabbing a QP.
QPS are always there. They're ready to go.
And so this is gonna
really simplify your lives.
Okay, so wrapping up.
Connections in DSQL.
Connections are secure.
In today's talk, we spoke about
how every connection in DSQL
is running in its own microVM,
using best in class hardware
level virtualization
and end-to-end encryption
between your application in DSQL.
Even members of the DSQL service team
cannot run something like
TCP dump and see your data.
There is end-to-end encryption.
It's secure out of the box.
We actually encourage
you to just run against
our public endpoint.
Take advantage of those tokens
because you don't have to
worry about credential leaks,
keep them short-lived.
But if you want,
you can set a private link
and configure resource-based policies
to lock down those
connections to your VPC.
Connections in DSQL are scalable.
It's the job of the
service team to make sure
that there's enough capacity
out there for every customer,
even if they're all spike.
You can use as many connections
as you need or as few,
and you're only gonna pay
for what you're doing
on those connections.
So if you have a hundred connections
and you're only using one connection,
you're only paying for the
activity on that one connection.
Connections in DSQL are designed
to be as simple as possible.
There's no patching,
there are no maintenance windows in DSQL.
There's no need to run
PgBounce or RDS proxy.
And there's no single point of
success in the system, right?
This is a system that has
no single point of failure.
It's strongly consistent.
And this is really gonna simplify your job
as an application developer.
And then connections are
snappy, they're fast.
Think about everything
we spoke about today.
We have AZ local routing.
We are going to a very fast
service written in Rust.
We're doing placement out of memory.
And we are grabbing a
connection out of a warm pool.
Once you've got that connection
open, connections are fast.
You're basically speaking
directly into that QP
that's ideally running
in the same AZ as you.
And the service has been designed
to handle mass reconnect storms.
So if all of your
connections die at there,
some kind of networking event,
we have extremely generous
default threatening rules,
this will allow you to get back online
as quickly as possible.
And with that said, that's
the end of the talk.
Thank you so much for attending.
My name is Marc,
I'd love to chat to you after the talk
if you have any questions.
Thank you for attending.
Have a great re:Invent.
And please do complete the
session survey in the mobile.